do you feel like out of all the big
movies you've done and you've done big
[__] movies
is and be honest you will be yeah
do you feel the most precious uh
pressure with Superman I did up until I
finished the script
now it's fun
you love the script I love the script
and people love the script and so like I
feel great about the script right I felt
a shitload of pressure at the beginning
like what am I doing
why am I doing this do you go through
those phases why am I doing this
definitely but I think that it was you
know people know I was offered Superman
years ago
I said no because I I didn't know quite
how to tackle it
and
um I think that you know but because of
that I kept thinking about it and
thinking about it and thinking about how
could I create a Superman that's true to
the character of Superman that
absolutely loves the character Superman
and yet is a take on Superman that's
different enough that it's worth you
know making a big budget movie about it
um that it's worth people seeing it that
it won't be boring you know all of those
things so uh so yeah so now I I yeah so
now I feel good about it so now it's fun
now we're just finding and and then I
felt a lot of pressure frankly
finding you know casting the roles sure
and you know saying God is there Eve I
know how hard it was so hard to find
Star-Lord I can't tell you I looked at
hundreds oh yeah I met with you you did
yeah and you know yours was the worst it
was yeah I'm aware of it
no I mean I saw so many people from Star
Wars I couldn't find the right person
until Chris
um and so I was worried about that but
now that we've kind of done a lot of
auditions when we're narrowing it down
we're not done yet by the way there's a
lot of stories out there about who we're
auditioning and all these screen tests
you know I'm just saying it's not all
true that's for sure like there's things
in there that are completely false but I
I can't go out there and say oh this
isn't true and this isn't true without
saying you know can I ask you this going
through everything and by the way it's
not the audience is you know right now
at this point I don't think it's the
business of anyone who's screen testing
for a role that is a very private thing
so someone does that shut your mouth
someone's putting well listen
journalists have to do what they have to
do that's their job how about a
journalist fight they're trying to get
hits
they find out some things from agencies
but here's the problem is that they find
out some things from agencies that might
be true they find out other things from
agencies which are agencies pushing
their clients and trying to Pump It Up
like look don't you see it because
there's been some things out there I'm
like why I think Mike this person I
think my client is testing yeah so it's
like it's like there's a lot of nonsense
that comes out of it and that's that's
difficult because there's people out
there that are supposedly testing that
aren't and that must be difficult for
them as people uh and there's other
people that might be testing that might
be testing yeah and that are out there
that might be testing and I think it's
not it it's a private thing between me
and them or someone that puts themselves
on tape and then they say oh I tested
well you put yourself on tape that well
that happens too that happens well the
thing that you know that happens also is
people say hey they offered me this
movie like directors do that I had that
with somebody who's on my podcast saying
oh yeah they offered me the Rolex Luther
ago no they didn't they didn't offer
anybody the Rolex then I called the
Creator and go hey dude this gives no
yeah that's yeah no we had somebody say
that we had these directors say it about
a DC project they offered us this
project I'm like no no they met with one
of our Executives about potential
projects to pitch on right that isn't
the same as yeah probably you just have
to let it go and go I'm not [__] even
entertaining this yeah you know what I
mean so but whatever the case there's a
lot of untruths out there sure um let me
ask you this or just promise that or
will the Lex Luthor character they'll be
a Lex Luthor right
then isn't that already known yeah they
think everybody thinks there's a Lex
Luthor out there but I've never said
there was Alexa there in there all right
so if there were Alexa if there were
Alex Luther okay if there were Alex
Luther in this movie and there's a lot
of other villains so it may not be like
you are the best Lex let's admit it we
know you're the best Lex come on you're
being funny I'm not being funny you're
definitely the best Lex really
definitely
but not right for your movie not right
for money I didn't say there was even
Alexa I know but if there were elects
Luther
promise me this uh-huh
you'll he'll be
he'll have gravitas or he'll have uh
he'll have a he'll he'll be Lex Luthor
he won't be playing playing Lex Luthor
but he's more acting like this character
or this or goofy or crazy he's gonna be
something that's grounded and real I
know you I'm sure that's everything yeah
yeah everything's right because I'm not
saying anybody's done that I'm just
saying that that you know maybe if
somebody's done that maybe maybe that's
happened